foreign
capital city
where do the fewest obese people live
North London
the most
East London
the weight disparity between largely
white and largely immigrant residents
might seem to concern race
but I will argue against the tide as
right now everything is about race
that deep down the fat differential
isn't ethnic the American and British
media have chided for months about
higher covered fatality rates among
minorities
and I've previously cast Medical dubiety
on the fashionable claim that these
patients are dying of racism
released last month a statistically
meticulous Columbia University study of
some 7000 cases validates my skepticism
as the New York Times reported
the study did not find race or ethnicity
to be an independent risk factor
the researchers did find extreme obesity
to be a strong independent risk factor
for Worse outcomes
indeed when isolated from conditions
like diabetes that corpulence can
trigger
obesity alone raises the likelihood of a
dire coveted response by fostering
inflammation and breathing difficulties
The crucial variable isn't race
it's fat
patients with extreme obesity a BMI of
40 or more
almost three times more likely to die
from covid Than People of normal weight
those with a BMI of 45 or more were four
times more likely to die
and poundage is as perilous for young
people as for the over 60s
the cross-atlantic correlation between
weight and ethnicity is awkward
a staggering 42 percent of all Americans
are obese nine percent extremely so
the same figure as for the white
majority
the prevalence of obesity among blacks
is nearly 50 percent
among Hispanics 45 percent
among mostly East Asians only 17 percent
after three hours of digging online
I can only conclude that the British
breakdown of adult obesity by race is a
closely held state secret
UK obesity rights are only widely
available under the combined category of
overweight and obese whose greater
breadth would have a leveling effect
Countrywide
about 62 percent
black 74 white British
63 percent
mostly South Asian 57 percent and South
Asians apparently suffer size-related
ill health at lower weights than whites
Chinese 35 percent
I can at least verify that in Britain
black and Pakistani women are especially
prone to wider waistlines
so if you've reached the same quiet
conclusion anecdotally it's not because
you're a bigoted
at least
not only because you're a big
in both countries why are blacks
especially so heavy when bringing
themselves to elude to this phenomenon
at all
condescending liberal commentators bend
over backwards to remove personal agency
from living with the burden of obesity
well themselves eagerly embracing fads
like the 5-2 diet
as if the privileged dumped fat on
unsuspecting minority neighborhoods
through an underhanded scheme of
corporeal fly tipping
yet many popular external explanations
don't wash
the problem is not food deserts where
shops don't sell greens
the NHS would never want this secret out
but you could credibly thrive on chips
and fried chicken as long as you called
it quits after a couple of drumsticks
and Chuck the rest in the fridge
Weight Wise quantity matters more than
quality
the problem is not poverty per se
healthy food is not necessarily
expensive
broccoli in the UK costs 50p
an enormous cauliflower a couple of quid
I cook
in my regular shop consistently costs
less than the trolley full ahead mounded
with ready meals
the problem is not poor health education
a 10 year old of any color has figured
out that pizza makes you fat and lettuce
doesn't
the problem is not poor English
because lettuce is low calorie in any
language
and anyone who hasn't understood this
ceaseless impotent hectoring directives
from the mercifully defunct Public
Health England
has been lucky
in the UK the problem is not lack of
Access to Health Care
because we have the free NHS
an institution so helpless in the face
of rising obesity the GPS are now
reduced to prescribing
bicycles
I lost my older brother to the
complications of obesity
while writing my subsequent 2013 novel
Big Brother
I gave fat a lot of thought
I don't believe this is a racial problem
it's a class problem
those obesity figures for white
Americans and white britons disguise a
profound subdivide
however ironically given how much face
stuffing the well-off could afford
most successful whites eat less than
struggling whites
just as they're also far less likely to
smoke
in the West
most successful people from any
background are underpron to overeat
granted I over generalize
nevertheless one key to success is
developing a capacity for delayed
gratification you do your homework
before you play
enjoy eating ice cream as much as
anybody
but an attractive healthy body is a form
of human capital
to refrain from polishing off the
Haagen-Dazs is to protect your wealth in
a larger sense
it's an investment in your future
among whites and non-whites alike stuck
on a social stratum that cultivates low
expectations
overeating constitutes a refusal to
invest in a future in which this cohort
has little faith
my broke demoralized brother ate out of
hopelessness
there's no reason to protect human
capital that's buying you nothing
if the future looks dim
it makes perfect sense to indulge in
immediate gratification
because the Kebab sitting on that
takeaway wrapper is the only kind of
gratification you're apt to see
this is not I repeat not a character
failing
it's a sign of rationality
oh other factors pertain like cultural
norms not only within minority
communities but across the board in both
countries whose cultures have
reconfigured the human proportions now
considered ordinary
in the American Midwest for example
chunky has become simply what people
look like
yet at core this issue still seems
teleological
it's fun to eat and it's way more fun to
eat carrot cake than carrots
to refrain from forking all that cream
cheese icing
you need a long range goal that's more
important than pleasure in the present
too many people
don't have one